un vote à main levée pour choisir des
idées apportées pendant la campagne une
vingtaine de militants et sympathisants
écologistes a lancé le comité de soutien
yvelinois yannick jadot ce samedi 29
janvier c'est le candidat qui porte le
mieux les sujets de l'écologie dans
l'ensemble sur
des fonds alloués aux travaux
d'isolation des bâtiments par exemple
qui peut amener
pas mal d'employeurs je crois que c'est
assez clairement évident c'est un des
candidats de forces capables de porter
l'ensemble des valeurs écologistes art
non seulement les valeurs écologistes
mais aussi toutes les valeurs
nécessaires pour là pour diriger un pays
au titre comme président je soutiens
unis jadot parce que c'est celui qui
fait émerger le plus d'idées pour
pour être dans la transition écologique
pour préserver notre environnement et
pour faire prenez la justice sociale et
je pense que c'est le meilleur candidat
pour la présidentielle pour défendre ses
idées et valeurs un lancement sous forme
d'ateliers dans l'idée de sortir des
partis faire entrer la société civile
pour créer un socle ce comité local a
choisi de mettre en avant l'idée
d'abaisser le nombre de signatures pour
un référendum d'initiative citoyenne et
la mise en place des modalités de vote
le candidat écologiste est actuellement
crédité de 5% des intentions de vote on
veut aller vers un électorat aussi jeune
qui est parfois un électorat qui va
surtout à s'abstenir et on veut leur
dire que voilà yannick jadot est là
aussi pour représenter la jeunesse et
que maintenant il faut il faut aller
voter pour qu'on prenne un petit peu
plus de décision dans le pays on va à la
rencontre des citoyens en allant sur les
marchés ou sur les gars en tractant
alors présentant le programme de yannick
jadot ou discutent avec eux les gens
sont quand même relativement intéressé
malgré tout même si ces sont des villes
qui vote majoritairement à droite
habituellement mais il ya quand même un
électorat de gauche et un électorat qui
est intéressé par l'écologie à la
primaire populaire s'est tenue ce
dimanche près de quatre cent mille
personnes se sont exprimées une
consultation citoyenne remporté par
christiane taubira yannick jadot a
rejeté son appel à l'union tout comme
jean luc mélenchon et anne hidalgo